let me talk about providers that are
organized in a way that I'll enable them
to deliver the right care at the right
price there's a set of of providers that
we call an integrated fixed fee provider
and that is these people employ their
own doctors so the doctors can be
compensated by keeping their patients
well not when they get sick and they
charge their patients they charge their
members a fixed annual fee and then
provide whatever care is needed within
that fee but that means that the
organization itself profits from keeping
the patients well whereas most of
healthcare the only way you can profit
is when the patient gets sick so Kaiser
Permanente in Northern California is one
of these Intermountain Healthcare in
Utah and Idaho looks like that guy's
injure in Pennsylvania looks like that
the Mayo Clinic is structured like that
and they're the ones i think that are
best positioned to execute the kind of
disruption that has to occur